[Music]
three easy reasons to visit miami
the weather
the beach
and of course the food
known for its caribbean and latin
american influences there are some
famous dishes that call this city home
but we are here for a few under the
radar spots that still serve up the
classic heat miami is known for
first up a cuban dish but it might not
be what you'd expect
[Music]
if you tell my grandfather to put cheese
on the fritta he'll tell you that's a
cheeseburger not afrida hi i'm george
lepore i'm the co-founder and managing
partner at cuban guys restaurants
frida guana is our version of the great
american hamburger
to make fritta guana we get ground beef
and we season it with a blend of
ingredients that gives it a smoky
chorizo taste
we shred the potatoes and cook the
frittata in the flat grill and it gives
it a nice crunch it tastes so good that
it needs no other ingredients back in
cuba carts were lined up in the streets
like they do with hot dog carts selling
frittas
miami has known the frida since the
early 50s when cuban exiles started
coming to the miami shores i remember
having a friday right around 12 years
old and it's been my passion ever since
next we found an over-the-top sweet spot
to follow savory
what's better than donuts what's better
than ice cream donuts and ice cream
together
it's a whole bunch of flavors it's
something over the top and and that's
what i love
my name is tony bahu i am the owner of
eonuts we are home of the smash donut
located on northwest 136th avenue in
sunrise florida in the greater miami
area so to make a smash donut it's very
simple we take a glazed doughnut we cut
it in half we put a scoop of ice cream
in it
the magic is we hot press it after it's
done we put some toppings on top
we have cereal toppings we have drizzles
we have sprinkles we have really cool
things the beauty of the smashed donut
is the outside is hot the inside stays
cold so you get texture you get flavor
you get temperature you get it all i
just absolutely love watching people try
smash donut for the first time whether
it's an adult a child a big kid whatever
it is just to see that expression on
their face when they try to smash donut
is super super exciting
at one of miami's longest running west
indian grocers there's one dish you
really shouldn't miss my ancestors went
for the caribbean from india and that's
how routine come about my name is nafisa
ali my store name is b m market
located at
21979 street miami florida i've been in
this location for 29 years roti is a
flat bread you make wraps with it as
well as eat it like a piece of bread too
you make a dough then we cut them into a
small size dough roll it out and fill it
with spooky and you bake it on a flat
pan the most popular filling is the jerk
chicken goat the shrimp also the ackee
and saltfish
has a real nice soft smelly texture when
it's really fresh right off the stove
sometimes flaky
very tasty too but roti takes a lot of
practice you have to have the passion
the love the excitement
when you find a really good kebab spot
you shouldn't keep it to yourself so
here you go you're welcome
this is like a german turkish fusion
since i'm like half german half turkish
the food reflects me
my name is oliver fryen the name of my
restaurant spitfire kebab we're located
in a 405 15th street on washington
avenue in miami beach we're making donut
from scratch kabob is made of fresh
bread we slice the bread up we put the
protein in it we have beef chicken or
falafel we garnish it with some salads
like the red cabbage the white cabbage
cucumbers tomatoes and the onions and we
top it off with some tzatziki sauce this
is an explosion of flavors people they
never tried the food before and they got
impressed i opened up this place in
2015. i grew up with this food over in
germany where i learned all the
authentic recipes since we have a lot of
turkish people over there
donna kebab was born in berlin i'm
bringing the original authentic tastes
to the states
[Music]
and finally we have a woman using her
multicultural heritage to create a new
flavor profile
my mother is spanish and my father's
japanese this dish is a unique product
of that perfect combination hi i'm chie
and i'm the owner of yoko matcha it is
located on 26th street and northwest 2nd
avenue in wynwood miami one of our
signature dishes is the matcha pasta
pastelito is a very popular cuban pastry
we found a way to incorporate matcha
into it so the dough is cut up into
pieces and the filling is placed on top
of the dough the matcha filling is made
with matcha
white chocolate cream cheese and
condensed milk the rest is a secret
once it's fully baked and it's delicious
we take it out we let it cool down and
drizzle more matcha and white chocolate
on top and it's that perfect combination
of sweet and bitter this is the best
matcha ever
[Music]
you